the Joe Rogan experience nothing there's
nothing about the way you talk that's
contrived and that's what's lacking what
people are lacking is people it bothers
people when you're talking to someone
and they're doing like the Morning News
guy boys you don't even know who the
[ __ ] that guy yes yeah you have no idea
whether it's a style of talk that they
make them do if they want to tell the
news in the morning but you don't have a
goddamn clue as to who that guy is when
you talk about something you have zero
of that you have zero of that fake thing
that you're trying to project out there
the fake things weird things gentleman
very good to see you this evening we're
having a wonderful time here at the show
and you see darkness behind that guy's
eyes he's talking like you know what you
know it evidently I think they come from
where I had no choice but to be myself I
kind of molded myself I never was raised
with rules so now trying to be fake it's
harder for me to be fake it is for me to
be real like I can't I'd be trying to
put on the face don't work like I'd be
really won't to be fake because it
sounds like it worked for other people
but I can't like I'd be trying to so
it's like easier for me to be to be just
genuine and it's because I'm not good at
lying like that yeah it's definitely
easier to be genuine but Solaris that
you tried to be fake how would you ever
try to be fake cuz I'd be working for
this man like [ __ ] what did you do what
did you do where you tried like just
trying to go in the room and do the
industry talk [ __ ] and act like I can't
like I don't like it just get boring and
[ __ ] so thank God thank you I never I
never gave a [ __ ] about I never gave a
[ __ ] about only that won't be famous
just to be with the people I never gave
a [ __ ] about the industry part of it
like that I I may because I've been
doing it long time now in my world maybe
that's what it is so I don't intrigue me
as much you know it's like [ __ ] a
[ __ ] a thousand times maybe that's what
it is but oh no don't do nothing for me
like that
what does it do what the the
entertainment part of it gets me to
where I can get to the
that's what I use it for like I love the
people for real and then in the front
everybody's like I recently found out
Harriet Tubman is my I like blur not for
real like so it kind of makes me like so
that's why I figured like that like I do
like helping the people you do like
helping she's a great heart
yeah my granny said my name's on the UH
statute well I got that to see my brain
is my brain your brains are statue numb
see I got my brain no man I'm saying I
got the statue in here in my brain my
brain is an acronym your names on the
statue oh yeah yeah the brains on iCloud
yeah my name is on the Harriet Tubman
stitch have you always been like Donna
did did that change at all when you
started smoking weed you know I was
always loved people I've always that's
what my name come from just representing
Jacksonville Duval
I've always did that so whenever I can't
wrap it it's in my name so it kind of
like psychologically for a person is my
from there it makes them see something
because you are what you see so that's
what I always used that name really good
to elevate the people from where you
came from
yeah that's beautiful that's a beautiful
name for a name that might be one of the
best names Duval yeah because that the
the sentiment behind it was one of the
best names I've ever heard I love that I
love that you doing that but I love the
thought behind it that was the hotel
from day one I mean I've always knew I
was like even where I grew up it always
knew like I supposed to be in this [ __ ]
then I was like maybe God put me here to
see this [ __ ] for that reason to get out
and tell everybody that you can get out
too not just to be example you know cuz
I mean I think the world's gonna evolve
us gonna evolve but I don't want the
people from around front to get left
behind to so it's just like I let me
show y'all with what's going on so you
can get a chance to be in the same
situation
hmm just to see the world a little more
you know so that's all that's why
behold let me find this so that's a
great name and the great reason for a
name man yeah but Harriet Tubman
so just the Harriet Tubman thing just
made me realize like him that's why
maybe I'm like this it just all goes
back to the nature thing we were saying
like it's it's in us over time you
started realizing that might really be
where it does come from I mean who knows
and all the traits like that to come
from besides learning from the people
and my grandfather that's not even like
my blood grandfather I grew up with
three grand daddies and I didn't realize
that was normal till I got older but he
was always in the community in
Jacksonville so I think I get like that
from watching him growing up it's wrong
away yeah yeah if he's a mentor figure
and you saw the benefit that he got out
of it I don't even know if I saw the
benefit I just think it's just come
second nature you are what you become I
mean you are what you see in this that's
just the way I moved from around older
people like I've always been around
older people and then think older people
who people that was raised by older
people they end up being alright because
older people teach you the right values
in life hmm my first friends was old
people all of my these that bridge
parties and [ __ ] here go search got [ __ ]
you know they [ __ ] in the brain it's
got to remember like oh let me think
about that thing seriously what data
planet you want on that like I'm
learning [ __ ] okay what he got here
oh that's the room that's what it was
the wrong way so you know [ __ ] I had
just posted on well that's the the
monument in Bristol Pennsylvania some
[ __ ] like that in Bristol and is it just
her living surviving relatives on the
monument yeah yeah all the names of all
the names of the people that Wow they're
good money that's all my mama my sister
my my
my nephew all that's on it that's some
dope [ __ ] you know so I could talk [ __ ]
about that to be like first or maybe you
ain't got nobody grandma great-grandma
Harriet Tubman though I wonder how much
of that actually gets in your genes all
that dude it's just like an athlete like
athletes the next athlete be better and
better than the other yeah natural
genetics
this is naturally any that's my
experience this is like just natural
experience we probably met full spirits
ago probably yeah yeah like maybe we're
out like like if we are both living the
same life over and over and over again
we've probably done this couple times
yeah
maybe sir for sure heavy doe neck
[Applause]